what's it like down there it's fantastic  when my friends and i started it was for  us the pleasure of discovering  in order to go deeper in order to stay  longer i became an inventor by necessity  that's when i understood the power of  images after all  we began to see that the things that we  had at night were beginning to decay  and we said we have to do something we  have to enter the fight  because you only protect what you love  is he a scientist  researcher  philosopher man looking at the future  can you tell me what you think are your  greatest accomplishments i am not  interested in myself i'm interested in  the world outside  you